I've been drawing my 2D friends like
this but I'm worried that might not make
sense for many reasons but the one I'll
address here is that they are lacking
bilateral symmetry for the most part
humans have a line of symmetry down our
bodies the left and right look mostly
the same as long as you don't look too
closely we probably became this way
because there was no advantage to having
a different left and right side when we
move in the left right directions it's
all much of the same we don't have a
line of symmetry across our bodies
because up and down are different in our
environment it would be a disadvantage
to have feet in the sky and a head on
the ground where all the obstacles are I
suspect flatlings in 2D should also have
bilateral symmetry with one eye on
either side either that or we might have
to accept that they can bend their neck
really far backwards so that they can
see what's behind them